[Music]
everyone welcome to the session best
practices for SCP deployments on CCP my
colleague Babu tech lead SCP on GCP and
myself will cover with you today we have
prepared the following again agenda
first I will give you an overview of GCP
in the context of SCP workloads I will
do that by mentioning typical components
of a s ET ET PSAP deployment on CCP and
recap the most important things about
these components a short note on some of
the slides you will find some references
to related sessions to the content shown
on the slides then my colleague Babu
will give you an overview of SAT in the
context of GCP and we'll move on to best
practices and reference architectures
then I will take over and will present
some migration best practices and
options how to bring your workloads to
GCP finally we will show a short demo
and have a Q&A so let's start with
giving an overview of GCP in the context
of SCP workloads if you look at a
typical SCP deployment on CCP it
normally consists of the following
components first you need to think about
how to connect to TCP data centers
second you need to think about a proper
networking setup third you need to think
about compute resources where you want
to host your SCP workloads on and you
need to think about storage either with
the VM as persistent storage or globally
through our global storage offering GCS
then another aspect is you want to be
sure that the about the health of your
systems this can be achieved via
monitoring and finally the whole thing
is summed up we are all built till up
until
curity concepts so let's talk about
compute what you have to remember is
that the new the network throughput
scales with the amount of CPUs maxing
out at 16 gigabits per second through
life immigration and active auto restart
we can provide you with higher
reliability that means that during a
software hardware update the VM is moved
to another host transparently this gives
you a better resilience for all levels
below the operating system through
sustained use discounts a customer has
the choice to and only pays for what
they use meaning the longer they use a
resource in a month the less the more
distant account to get moving on to
persistent disk as I mentioned before
with compute engine throughput and IAP
scale with the size of the disk and
depending if you are using HDD or STD
you have different read or write metrics
as can be seen here for STD workloads
which are our higher performance option
you have 800 megabyte bits per second
bytes per second read and 400 megabytes
per second write
but another deciding factor with SSDs is
the amount of vc peels you will reach
this maximum performance metrics only if
you have more than 32 CPUs
additionally worth mentioning is that
our persistent disk can save up I owe
capabilities to handle IO spikes well
above the average and also worth
mentioning is that typical operation
tasks like partitioning and read under
disk arrays as well as sub volume
management are not necessary with it now
moving on to to networking when we talk
about our software-defined network and
compare it to a typical on tram
deployment our B pcs can span regions
meaning they are a global resource our
subnets can spend songs meaning the
original resource they can
non-overlapping address space and can be
dynamically extended through share PPC's
we provided a possibility to have a V PC
as a shareable resource that can be
managed by a central networking team and
another thing is to consider when
talking about performance for in treviño
munication use internal IPS / external
IDs and rightly sized your TCP window
now talking about how to connect to TCP
you have the following options for a low
bandwidth connections which are
connecting via the public Internet you
can use VPN which provides you 1.5
gigabits per second if you want to save
up to 50% on us cost compared to the VPN
object and want to connect via public IP
you can either use direct or carrier
peering depending if you meet Google's
peering requirements if you want to
connect via private IP and want to have
an SLO SLA sorry then you have either
dedicated interconnect or para in a
partner interconnect dedicated
interconnect provides you with 10
gigabits per second the link partner
interconnect provides you with a range
of 50 megabits per second or 10 gigabits
per second per link talking about
security of this context especially
encryption Google encrypts all data by
default with Google's internal kills but
additionally Google gives you the option
to use customer-supplier encryption keys
meaning that you provide the ask the
keys keep them on premise and only if we
want to retrieve or store data we we
need them in between we have cloud
management service that lets that lets
you keep kissing TCP have them
automatically used by GCP as needed but
control things like he rotation or
revoke a revocation of the keys now
moving to the last point of those
components
monitoring through our joint work with
SVP we could provide specific
stackdriver agents which hook into
netweaver and hana they can give you the
possibility to see in one singular view
the health and detail about your SCP
deployment on ccp through textiles
alerting mechanisms you have the
possibility to get notified in case of
any incidents and through aggregated
logging you have the possibility to get
a high-level overview of your SCP
deployment amongst multiple project with
that I will give it to my colleague
Pavel we will now show you an overview
of SCP in the context of TCP Thank You
Jeremy can I have a quick show of hands
how many people here have experience
running in safety workloads ok how many
of you have experience running in Sabre
workloads in the cloud any cloud ok so
that's ok cool so in this section I'm
going to talk about cover 2 two
important things two important topics
the first topic is what s ap services
and solutions are certified to run on
GCP and the second topic is what are the
benefits of bringing your s AP workloads
to run on Google cloud platform so we
have been working with s AP starting
from q1 of 2017 for multiple
certifications technology integrations
you've come a long way in the past one
year we go through a rigorous functional
and performance testing for each
certification that we make available for
productive use for customers if you look
at netweaver we run something called as
a three-tier benchmark to prove linear
scalability of our virtual machines for
example we will take the netweaver stack
we will run
application on a single VM will create
the database on a separate VM we will
run the SD benchmark we will look at the
saps numbers such as ASAP the
application performance standard let's
say the SAPS numbers is 100 for example
if you create another VM and you run the
same workload with two VMs you should
get 200 sets that's basically you prove
linear scalability that's when you get
certified we have a few net we were
colleagues years who can attest to that
so we go through all of that to make
sure that customers have the best
possible experience when they are
bringing their a CPU were closed to run
on GCP vo also certified custom vm types
for customers to run their s4 Hana
workloads on Google cloud platform what
this essentially means is let's say you
do a sizing exercise and you determine
that based on the PSAPs that you need
you need an instance with approximately
20 course but if you look at the
predefined machine terms machine types
available in many platforms including
Google cloud you will not fight you will
find a 16 core machine and a 32 core
machine you'll not find a 20 core
machine that's when custom virtual
machines will help you write so with
this certification you can run machines
virtual machines with the exact amount
of course that you need based on the
PSAPs that you have basically if you
look at the 20 core versus the 32 core
comparison you're basically saving 60%
in terms of resource and costs just by
using custom VM types we've also worked
with ASAP to certify ASAP cloud platform
for Google cloud platform so if you're a
developer who's developing cloud foundry
applications s AP based applications
this is a platform that you can leverage
and you can build custom applications on
top of GCP with s AP cloud platform a CP
Hana is an in-memory database that
serves as a backing store for s AP
applications like s for Hana BW for Hana
and so on customers who use sa P Hana
require VMs with a large amount of
memory
so the slide here shows a rapid pace of
innovation that allowed us to go from
200 gigabytes of memory roughly last
year to 4 terabytes of memory this year
within a span of a year right and
through this process we also realized
that you can run scale out workloads
where you can scale out your SI p HANA
from a single machine to multiple
machines in a BW OLAP environment so our
scale out certification currently allows
you to go up to 16 nodes and 22
terabytes
for your BW OLAP workloads finally we
have also certified dynamic tearing this
is hot of the press for SI p Hana
workloads so if you look at sa P on si
PRS or in memory database memory is
expensive so and if you ask the question
whether your application requires all
the data that's in memory maybe maybe
not right so you decide at what point
the data becomes less interesting to
your application and you define a warm
tier to move the data to the let's say
the dynamic tearing portion right this
basically allows you to optimize costs
and also leverage the SI p Hana
certified ecosystem for storing large
amount of data at the same time right
and during this process we also made
sure that customers can deploy sa P Hana
in our environment in a matter of
minutes we developed automation
templates these automation templates can
do end to end stuff starting from
configuring virtual machines with
required amount of storage certified
configuration making sure high
availability is configured making sure
that there is automatic failover so for
example if one machine fails the other
machine automatically takes over within
a matter of seconds right so you can
satisfy the high availability and
disaster recovery requirements that you
have in mind already so this is just an
overview slide talking about a summary
of what we have achieved so far
so now let's move on and talk about
benefits why should you bring your SI p
workloads around GCP right so data
custodian is a partnership initiative
between SI p and google cloud in the GRC
space the governance risk and compliance
space google cloud we developed a
solution called a xt access transparency
which is a set of API is that we'll
expose to customers what is happening in
your infrastructure who is accessing
your data from the infrastructure
provider side so this is bundled into
the data custodian application to
provide more visibility where SA P acts
as a data custodian for customers data
in Google Cloud this is a unique
initiative in the public cloud space one
day between a Sapien Google Cloud today
I talked about dynamic tiering
integration earlier what if you have a
use case where you have petabytes of
data and you have to store these
petabytes of data and query the data at
the same time with high performance this
is where integrations like bigquery come
into picture with dynamic tiering you
have basically defined a hot and a warm
tier what if you could define another
tier where you can take the data that is
let's say greater than a year or greater
than three years depending on your
application needs and move it into
archive it off to bigquery but the
problem is when you archive it off to
another store you have to manage it
right but the thing with bigquery is
bigquery is a zero of state of Eros
which means that there is no servers no
software for you to manage you just
create a table and the table just scales
to the load to the data you throw at it
to the queries you throw at it there is
no concept of servers at all the server
loss data was literally right so now
this basically allows you to have
another layer scale to petabytes of data
without incurring any operational costs
right so how is this possible you can
basically make this possible through
leveraging multiple technologies like s
AP data services is one data hub is the
new kid in the block for all the
workflow orchestration and data
processing applications you can all
use data flow which is another
serverless processing data processing
application to archive data off to
bigquery from within a city hana now
what now you have data in ASAP hana you
have hot and one tears now you have data
and bigquery also how do you get a 360
degree view of all your data to four
good analytics processing right so this
is where we innovated it ASAP to make
bigquery as a native option available
through smart data access what this
essentially means is the bigquery tables
can be virtually accessible through a CP
Hana using smart data access so now you
can do things like creating a view that
encompasses let's say the heart warm and
cold here with bigquery bring them
together so when you do the query based
on what you're accessing that the query
is pushed down to whichever layer the
data exists and you get the results back
one thing you should not do here you
should probably not run full table scans
on bigquery because when you do that
you're basically going to page out all
the active data in memory sitting in a
recipe Hana database right but then if
you run queries that materialized data
you can just get the process results
back because SDA just pushes the query
down directly to bigquery now let's talk
about machine learning I'll just talk
about one one portion of this here we're
partnered with Deloitte and Deloitte has
actually built a cool solution to solve
the invoice management problem this is a
business process problem so the solution
looks like this right let's say you have
invoices that you're getting and you
need to input these invoices digitizes
invoices in an S for Hana system right
typically you'd have a data operator you
will read the invoices will in input the
data and the s for Hana system and then
he has to basically copy the invoice
data storage somewhere library write
what the system does what the solution
that I write has built is it uses
Google's machine learning technologies
with OCR and you can basically take a
picture of the invoice and the solution
tool will basically extract the textual
information from the invoice populate an
invoice a digitized invoice in s4 on our
system
takes the original picture of the
invoice and stores it on a cloud storage
system reliably right this is all done
with a single solution and I've actually
mentioned where the solution is have
where the session is happening that's
happening tomorrow I would recommend to
for you to go and take a look at it so
if you are doing it yourself you can
develop continuous machine learning
deployment pipelines for example this is
an example where if you have data and I
say P Hana and you want to derive
intelligence from the data using the
power of machine learning available in
Google cloud you can take the data and
throw it into Google Cloud storage and
then you can use TP use just tensor
processing units available in Google
Cloud you can provision them as much as
you want and scale independently and
then develop your machine learning
models and then bring them to tensorflow
serving now Hana can basically consume
all the machine learning models through
tensorflow serving foster on compute
engine right so you can basically do
continuous model training you can as new
data comes in train it bring it back
intensive low serving new more new data
comes in train it bring it back to
tensorflow serving you can build a
continuous machine learning model Google
has been lab
innovating in the containerization space
we have been running containers for a
decade or so and we open sourced
kubernetes we also have a service called
google kubernetes engine which is a
managed version that allows you to
manage kubernetes services running in
Google cloud platform ASAP has
standardized many of their applications
to use kubernetes right so when you're
thinking about applications like s ap
data hub or wor they are standardized on
kubernetes which means that you can
leverage the managed kubernetes platform
that we have you don't have to manage
any server services pods everything is
fully managed for you you just know
kubernetes definition the container
definition files and we just basically
can run these workloads with minimal
operations so this is a quick demo an
architecture showing how you can
leverage data hub to bridge the Google
and s AP ecosystem together data hub
also has native integrations the new
version of data hub will have Nate
integrations with bigquery pub/sub and
Google Cloud Storage so if you are
basically developing big data processing
applications you can use data hub to
bridge the Google and s AP technologies
together so what are we doing for
developers right so we worked with s AP
to enable cloud appliance library so
today we have 80 plus solutions
available in cloud appliance library for
GCP so if you want to get started
quickly and build a sandbox environment
then play around the GCP you can get
started with Cal immediately so let's
talk about business continuity google
cloud exists across 17 regions today and
we are going to we are going to launch
three more regions by the end of this
year so we'll have 20 regions and all
these regions are connected by Google's
backbone network which means that you
basically have access to low latency
networking for all your infrastructure
needs plus within the within the
region's we also have the concept of
zones where you can architect your
applications to leverage multiple zones
and these zones are typically the zone 2
zone
latency is under 1 milliseconds at the
p95 level right which means that you can
leverage multiple zones and build highly
scalable applications across seasons you
can also develop BR strategies using
let's say you're using Hana system
application you can configure
asynchronous system replication across
regions and develop like a minimal or
poto solution let's talk about best
practices and reference architectures
now so everybody must be familiar with
it right I mean whoever has this ap
experience so this is a typical sizing
exercise that you go through when you
size your s AP workloads so you have the
s AP quick sizer
you input all your data as to how many
users you have how do you scale data
edging and all those things and then it
outputs apps number and then you take
the SAPS numbers to the infrastructure
problem in this case is GC P and we will
take a look at the number so you can
basically take a look at our
numbers in the ASAP note and then you
can map the instance types that you want
for your workloads based on the PSAPs
that you have I talked about custom VM
types earlier right so let's say you
have a PSAPs number let's say for 16
core machine you have 32,000 PSAPs and
32 core mission you're 64,000 PSAPs but
what if you have a PSAPs need that is
40,000 that's right in between these two
right this is where you can leverage
custom VM types for your workloads and
basically optimize your cost for ASAP
HANA this is a simple algorithmic
representation that I put together to
size your s AP Hana workloads so there
are four factors that you need to
consider right the first factor is what
source database are you migrating from
if you are migrating from something else
if it's a roster database like Oracle or
sequel server then you typically have to
accommodate the compression benefits
that you will get typically it could be
anywhere between 5 X - 10 X so let's say
you have a 20 terabyte Oracle database
you would size it at roughly between 2
to 4 terabytes for s AP Hana right
that's factor number one factor number
two is whether you're looking to any
data edging solutions like using dynamic
tearing or extension nodes and so on
right so when you do that your memory
footprint drastically reduces that's
another way of optimizing your memory
footprint costs as well the third thing
is if you are running OLAP workloads
typically sa P Hana rig has memory
overheads for example when you're
running queries it uses temporary space
to store the data in between during the
processing right so you have to
accommodate for those memory overheads
as well so that will be around 25 to 50
percent the fourth thing is accommodate
for future growth you are running a
database you're going to get data in
constantly you cannot predict for what's
going to happen today you have to
predict for what's going to happen down
the line
right but the cloud you don't have to
plan for three to five years because the
only thing that you have to do to scale
your inferences in the cloud is
basically stop and start on our larger
machine right but then you still have to
plan at least six months to one year in
advance that's something that has to go
into your sizing calculations as well in
you're doing sizing for ICP Hana so when
you are running netweaver workloads
on GCP this is something that is
mandatory for customers to install to
get product to support from sa P this is
matrix agent that we worked with ACP to
develop this agent gets you
infrastructure level metrics and
surfaces it to the SI P host agent which
will then consume these metrics this
will give you a single pane of view of
whatever is happening not only from the
SA P side but also from the
infrastructure side to the customer
right and this is something that's
absolutely mandatory if you want product
of support from sa p4 ASAP workloads
running on GC P so let's talk about
networking best practices so one of the
first decisions that you make
after the sizing and everything is
basically like which region do you want
to deploy your workloads in right so you
choose the region based on multiple
factors I have represented like three
factors here the first one is where does
your business process run you need your
region your infrastructure to be hosted
closer to where your business process is
running or where your client is that's
the first thing secondly let's say you
have a tie between two regions how do
you decide which region you want to
choose right so GCP or any cloud profit
for that matter will have different
pricing across different regions right
so that's something that you need to
consider you cannot assume that the
pricing is similar across all the
regions that we have across the cloud
that's not the case so you'll have to
look at pricing there's a second thing
third thing is when we launch new
instance types we eventually will launch
these instance types across all the
regions but intermediately these
instance types are going to be available
only in specific regions so when you're
thinking about your deployments you
should look at what instance types
you're choosing and whether these are
available in the regions that you are
choosing basically right or choose a
different region based on the
availability and when you are setting up
your infrastructure leverage private IPs
for cross node communication this is
this is a good practice especially for
latency
and costs and then you want to access
Google cloud platform services like GCS
for example to store your backups and
other things offload backups off you can
basically leverage private API access
which means that your virtual machine
doesn't have to have an access to an
Internet
but with the private API is that you
have you can access the Google Cloud API
is services natively the other thing is
in any ACP installation you have a
specific IP protocol port combination
through which traffic flows across the
system right for example you have
administrative components like SAP
router or solution manager that will
basically talk to the application stack
and within the applications to our sake
event queue application server and then
you have central services that talk to
each other for a chain and then from sir
and then from the application stack you
talk to the database right there is a
define traffic flow in your recipe
installation right you can design that
traffic flow by using network tags in
our VPC environment today now there are
going to be cases where you want to go
out out out of the bpc Network to the
Internet to get packages and things like
that right so that's when you leverage
nat right so in Google Cloud netting is
implemented differently
you throw a solution called ECM peanut
ecmp stands for equal cost multi path
where you can scale your NAT environment
by just adding more instances and adding
those instances to a routing table so
that it routes the packets that are not
belonging to the network or not targeted
to the network to the NAT instance right
so Jeremy talked about how our network
egress bandwidths are the scale up to 16
gigabytes per second for four machines
8 cores and above so if you wanna get
higher bandwidth than this
then you can basically use an ECM pin
absolution and scale it independently
and get how much of an ADD bandwidth you
want so let's talk about storage so one
thing that we absolutely recommend is to
avoid using local SSD for your s AP
or air applications we have certified
and tested using persistent disk which
is basically network attached storage if
you look at the persistent disk sizes
that you are supported you need at least
one point seven terabytes because that's
basically when you get the optimum
storage throughput for your data on logs
that you host on s AP Hana for backups
you need at least to exercise of DRAM so
that you can accommodate at least two
full full backup copies of a recipe Hana
database there are several cost
optimization sake in that you can do for
example if you have your management
components like SAP router and solution
manager in a dr environment you don't
have to have a VM and disks running on
the dr site for these management
components you can just take a snapshot
of these components and those snapshots
can just live there in a dr scenario you
can use the snapshots to bring up your
entire system together there's at least
the management components so you can do
some of these things to optimize in
terms of costs NFS NFS is actually one
of the major components in any ASAP
installation right so we have an avoid
option which is definitely something you
should not do but then you also have do
to yourself and DCP marketplace for
example in do-it-yourself we typically
recommend leveraging the NFS services
that is provided by the operating system
provider we also have single node filer
solutions available on our marketplace
if you look at the availability SLO stat
GC compute engine provides we offer four
nines of availability as allows for a
single VM running in a single zone this
is basically leveraging reliability
features like live migration automatic
instance restart which makes sure that
your VMs are up and running always even
in case of failures right so a single
node filer will typically satisfy your
SLA requirements if they are under 99.9
percent of availability SL O's we are
also coming up with new solutions we
have announced new solutions those are
going to be coming up in GA by the end
of this year so in terms of operating
system images right you're not going to
just take whatever images that people
that are available to you and just use
it right you're going to apply some
customization to these images then
you're applying customizations to these
images you will have to look at two
components the first component is what
portions of this customization do you
need every time a vm comes up and what
portions of this customizations do you
need to be updated once every three
months right so these are static and
dynamic component the static static
components need to be baked into the VM
image this will allow you to improve
boot up times so that when a new VM
comes up in case of a failure on some
event you have a faster prototype for
ian's but the dynamic things we cannot
do anything about it right that's
depends on how you pull the packages in
there are a couple of compute engine
best practices that I want to talk about
here right by default you need to enable
live migration an automatic instance
restart for all your SI p installations
this-this-this absolutely needs to
happen because we have seen clear
benefits when there are infrastructure
events when there are instance going
down when there are security events we
live migrate your virtual machines
without any downtime to your
applications without this enables your
VMs will basically crash right so this
is something that you need to do you
should also limit API access to specific
DCP services from within your VM for
example typically in a safe installation
you don't access many services you don't
access App Engine you don't access like
pub/sub and things like that right so
but you might access things like
bigquery and Google Cloud Storage so
when you are creating these instances
restrict access only to those API is
that you absolutely need access for now
let's talk about a few reference
architectures and then I'll close so
this is something where we show sa P
Hana H a reference architecture we have
a say P Hana primary hosted in zone 1
and you have s st persistent disk for
all your data and log volumes so that
you can satisfy your storage and
throughput requirements the backups are
returned to HDD that's another cost
savings that you have now once you have
this enabled you can create a similar
set up in Zone B you can enable you can
do the initial data load and then you
basically have system replication
configured you'll have a synchronous
data replication which basically works
because it zone to zone latency is under
one millisecond and you can configure
backups to cloud storage at this point
right so in the high availability setup
that we recommend you can also configure
automatic failover which means that if
zone a entirely goes down zone B
whatever is running in Zone B will take
over and start running your database as
if nothing happened in a matter of
seconds similar thing can be applied to
asynchronous replication in a dr
scenario where you will have the
databases across region a and region b
and then in this case instead of
configuring synchronous replication you
will have asynchronous replication
because you don't want every right to
block on a cross fan network so you
basically configure asynchronous
replication to achieve this so now in
this case you can reduce your RPO not
your requirements because there is
somebody who's waiting hot on the other
side to take over in this in a case
where the entire region a goes down
right now let's talk about scale out
sorry about all this animation so in a
scale out environment we typically
recommend installing it in a single zone
you will have masters and slaves all the
master and slave configuration should
live in a single zone one difference
here is that all the nodes in a scale or
cluster configuration should have their
own persistent disks do not use NFS for
data and logs in a scale or environment
at all use NFS one day for Hana share
for data on logs they are all on their
independent volume we are currently
working on announcing a solution for
high availability for scale or clusters
in Hana using the concept of standby
nodes but that's something that's not
out there yet but meanwhile you can
basically leverage instance reliability
capabilities like live migration and
automatic instance restart
so yep so I'll now hand over to Jamie to
talk about migration thank you
[Applause]
excuse me perfect since we have now
covered the possible reference
architectures and best practices let's
go over some options how to move
existing workloads to GCP given that you
have a proper network connection to our
these data centers in place
yeah the first option I will cover is
fellow strata winner strata is a
solution that allows you to quickly move
workloads into GCP it thereby takes an
agentless approach and does some
specific optimizations when moving data
into the cloud it takes the streaming
approach and performs a native boot over
there by a wide area network to
on-premise operating systems so while
the operating system boots it is adapted
on-the-fly to meet the cloud and ramp
environment requirements and then
streaming starts so only the data that
you need to to work with your workloads
in the cloud is streamed to the cloud
this technology is called intelligent
streaming and you can up after a few
minutes you can already use your
computer resources in TCP meanwhile
transparently the rest of the data is
migrated to the cloud and finally once
the synchronization is done you can do
the sweep a switch over to the VM in CCP
and still take or keep the backup that
you have on-premise
- Trotta uses some specific optimization
technologies like multi-tiered caching
deduplication optimist and synchronous
write back and network optimizations to
speed up this process another option
that you have is cloud under cloud
Endora takes a little bit of a different
approach here
it uses an age based approach and it
offers a central management console that
allows
or migrate the data but also to disaster
recovery so as soon as you install the
agent on your VM the streaming starts
and in the GCP the cloud induced servers
are set up and do the replication the
block level copy approach in difference
to Vella strata which uses a streaming
approach and once you have done the
migration and finished your testing you
are ready for a capital one and can
start using the machine in the cloud and
you can decide if you want to remove the
agent or if you want to keep on the
regular data replication so now that we
have talked about some options how to
move the data as is to the cloud I will
show you some scenarios how you could
use these tools scenario 1 or option 1
is you want to do a first step a simple
if use a tool like cloud indoor or
Venice Trotta
to move your data as is to the cloud and
already get the first technology refresh
however you will still have your
technical depth and need to address this
at a later point in time
nevertheless since you are already in
the cloud this is a much easier step so
many customers do this because they have
to go off of the current platform you do
contract contract expiration capacity
limitations or other non technical
reasons so the option of moving quickly
takes precedence the other option that
you could use or a other scenario that
you could use is to use TMO for that and
since the mo normally is an in-place
procedure that just works on the same
application server you could use vm o
with system mode for that that allows
you to migrate to another application
server therefore you can move your
workload
- GCP with this approach and so if you
want to bring your workloads to GCP we
work with various partners we have a
partner ecosystem that you can use to
implement your SCP workers and GCP and
bubble already mentioned some of them
for instance Deloitte Accenture and
others now that I have shown you the
migration part of the picture I will
move on into the demo part of the
session so I have prepared for you the
following demo bubble mentioned it
before we have the possibility of
deploying a high availability set up on
CCP and this can be achieved via
deployment manager which is which is our
infrastructure Zack O'Tool we have
provided you a deployment manager
templates which can leverage and deploy
a high availability set up in CCP it
uses Linux clustering and a virtual IP
address to do the simple switchover as
well as harness system replication so
now let me start the demo as you can see
on the first screen this is the pocket
where you normally store the Hana files
so you have a GCS pocket which will you
will reference in the deployment manager
manager template so this describes
actually the high availability setup and
further down you can see the comment
which executes this setup you can also
see the sample output of working
installation now I switch to stack
driver logging where you can see how the
normal logging output would look like on
a typically a che deployment on TCP you
will find some references to the buckets
you were using as well as the IP
addresses that I used and the virtual IP
addresses that is shared amongst those
two instances
and finally once the whole setup is done
you are greeted with the message inserts
deployment complete so you know the
deployment has been finished and I'm
switching over to hana studio to show
that the deployment works and you can
see all services are started as well as
the replication services started you see
the VM one as the primary host and the
VM 2 as the secondary host and a
replication type that is used now I log
on to VM Vaughn and will try to start a
failover meaning I will shut down the
one VM and show you how the failover
happens and how to take over is
happening so I log on as as
administrator and simply shut down the
network interface in Hubli that means
once the network interface is shut down
the VM automatically restarts now again
I moved to stack driver logging which
shows you exactly what is happening in
the cloud in this case it shows you ok a
VM is going down as you as you see I
have to refresh a little bit ok takes a
couple of seconds and you will see then
that the system detects ok a VM is down
and it does the takeover you can also
see that the virtual IP address that I
mentioned before will be changed to the
other host 2 VM 2 so as you can read
it's issuing a reset - and check it's
seeing that the VM is going down and the
10 124 is the virtual IP address that is
shared amongst the two instances now the
VM 2 is taking over
and I'll switch back to hana studio to
show you exactly that first the system
or vm2 has taken over the
synchronization is not currently running
it takes a couple of seconds again until
until the synchronization is properly
set up again so you can see now it says
vm 2 so it has switched the primary
hosts from vm 1 2 BM to
and you can see I'm getting a little bit
nervous what is happening
but now you can see the synchronization
is also kicking in the primary host is
VM to secondary host is begin one and
the replication mode is coming up so it
takes a couple of seconds of course when
the VM one is back up that the
replication can be started and with that
the failover is done and you still have
a running system and as I said this is
all provided out of the box via our
deployment manager templates you have
access to these templates you can
further look into the code that is
written there so its users ginger and
Python to script this and yeah you can
drill down and find out okay what is
happening you can also attach additional
logic if you need all to your liking
[Music]